i'm a an entrepreneur in a practical
type
for me the problem i was trying to solve
for seven years was that we weren't
creating enough new businesses and
entrepreneurship
and uh business growth and job growth in
communities around the country
and then i realized that the problems
were much bigger and deeper
but certainly andrew yang in his late
20s was not thinking any of this
andrea in his late 20s was just you know
trying to get a date i think what's
interesting and what captured
so many so much interest about your
candidacy and
and more was you didn't talk you talk
about it in terms of the fourth
industrial revolution obviously you know
we've i've interviewed you in the past
and you obviously understand
some of the deeper i mean obviously you
did the math but
you also spoke about it in a very
visceral way so when you were traveling
those
places and you're talking to these
people how did it come through
like in their stories because something
that i've always kind of come to
understand is that
elite economists and many others will
try to explain phenomena away by being
like no your job is gone but you might
you're better off because of x
and that when you actually talk to real
voters and people who have been you know
affected by
automation trade policy or last loss of
manufacturing they know exactly why they
lost their job
and the macro force that it kind of
brought about
so is that something that you saw like
whenever you were traveling
yeah they did know what happened
particularly in a place like detroit
where
the urban center emptied out for the
most part
and the population drained away
and they know that it was a combination
of globalization and trade deals and
offshoring and also
the automation of many of their
traditional manufacturing jobs so they
know
uh and i studied economics so
i understand the theory behind it you
know like oh comparative advantage
you'll be fine or you know you'll
learn how to do something that's higher
value-add but then you go there and that
stuff just seems farcical
you know you go there right and
there was a disconnect that i struggled
with and then trump won in 2016. i
started adventure of america in 2011. so
i've been doing that work for five years
and then trump wins and then i'm like
okay uh this is much deeper and nastier
and we're still we're still not being
honest about it somehow
so that that was what drove me but i i
am very interested in trying to figure
out the genesis of my
um uh of my approach in part because
uh you know i've been an operator and
entrepreneur for
20 years or so and
you know they're just like facts on the
ground that you have to deal with and if
you
tell yourself a nonsense story and
you're running a private company
you're going to fail
you know it's uh inevitable and so
you know i like to think i just traffic
in uh
as close a version of reality as i can
find uh because if if you're
operating from reality then you're more
likely to be successful
and one of the frustrations i found
sauger is that like
there's not a whole lot of trafficking
in reality that's going on right now
and it's going to destroy us because we
have this increasingly
in kuwait uh set of arguments
uh and one thing that someone said to me
is lawrence lessig
who said to me that we live in a
vitocracy right now where
i can't get anything done but i can keep
you from getting anything done right
and and so there's a lot of negative
power going on um and we're in an era of
unprecedented change
and so if you freeze government and say
no one can get anything done then you
wind up with
problems that just get bigger and bigger
and you become more and more behind the
curve and out of date
i think that's a really profound point
that you're making there andrew because
the
the main thing that you're observing is
that we can
stop things from other getting done and
like i was saying like i generally find
the whole shtick
about businessmen trying to run the
country that way
as pretty hokey because it's like well
no actually like a nation state it's not
a business and all that
but the one thing where i think it
absolutely does apply is to your point
was
is that if you keep if you do something
which is totally delusional
you generally your business should fail
like there should be at least some sort
of incentive theoretically that's in
democracy
like voters should vote you out if you
do fail and yet
we've kind of come to a system where you
have both parties which are
invested very much in an ideology which
has failed you know the fourth
industrial revolution as you call it
didn't really just occur
out of nowhere one of the you know the
deep one of the most pernicious things
that somebody told me
i won't name him because he's high level
in economics but he said you know
i'm unconvinced that the best scenario
for amazon
is not 10 unemployment or you know perma
10 to 15
unemployment and the reason being that
if you're in a rural or a small town
that the best pa the best paying job so
to speak and really the only option for
you
is to work in an amazon warehouse at a
very set wage in a not which is
non-unionized
and there is a level of you know
corporate control there
over the way that you're conducting your
life and your you know
uni you your singular option
of being able to live that i do think is
unacceptable how do you how have you
always looked at the monopolization
question because i know you toyed with
it you know
between tech and in the regular sector
too
i don't think we have truly reckoned
with what it means to have
trillion dollar companies that dominate
so much
of our waking life uh you know and it
was
to me a source of great amusement
watching these trillion dollar companies
pretend to be scrappy startups in front
of congress the other week
it was like oh you know we're not number
one at all
we could be upended any day by those
tick tockers or whatever
it's like we wouldn't have crushed
instagram no like
you know it's like the whole thing i was
like oh no i said
like watching them uh try and recast
themselves
um yeah that that
their consequences of having companies
of that scale
uh are unknown to us
uh but they're extreme and one of the
things i kept saying to folks is like
look at this point
um amazon no longer uh has to obey the
rules of business physics anymore it's
just like this voracious black hole
you know it's like it could decide not
to make money in a given quarter and it
would still be
a trillion dollar company uh you can't
compete with them in any meaningful way
they have
uh essentially unlimited resources and
access to more data than anyone else
uh you know that like they're they'll
trumpet the fact that they're hiring
tens of thousands of americans while uh
while retail is shutting down and i mean
made light of it earlier about
what's going to happen uh and and so the
the old tool kit would be like we'll
break them up
and i think that there needs to be a
breakup of some of these companies in
some
verticals but i also don't think that
actually solves the problem
because you wind up with uh still
these network effects that just
advantage whatever company is
is at the hub and right now our
government is so bad at this where
we're essentially 25 years behind the
curve so any company that's come into
existence over the last 25 years were
like don't know
like don't know what you're doing uh and
then we have this mistrust of government
being like well you're
slow and behind the times and they're
really smart at
times they should decide what to do
and and that that's been one of the ways
we're conditioned
so the optimal path
would be that we go to each of the big
four
or five companies and just say look we
have company specific issues with you
trying to apply a one-size-fits-all
antitrust framework doesn't even make
sense
right uh like we're gonna have to craft
tailored legislation
and figure out what the worst aspects of
your
enormity are and then circumscribe them
so in facebook's case it might be like
well what are our biggest beefs with you
the the erosion or or
near decimation of our democracy i would
say would be the top of the list
and then the the fact that they sell and
resell us in our data for
tens of billions of dollars a year might
be second and then the third might be
uh the fact that they have a near
monopoly on uh
certain types of social media because
they did buy instagram and whatsapp and
so maybe we have to
to do something about that and then
there might be mental health of our kids
associated with instagram
use you go down the list and just try
and figure out what
what each issue is like i'm not against
size for sizes sake i'm against size if
it ends up
hurting us in various ways and then
you'd have to write company-specific
legislation
um for facebook essentially don't
pretend it's like we're going to take
out a 20th century
framework before the internet even
existed back when they're talking about
you know picking like this company makes
too much steel
you know like it's a very very different
world now
yeah i think it's it's funny you said i
what i always loved about your campaign
was the feeling that i wasn't living in
ossified washington you know like
because i covered these guys on capitol
hill and so much more and it was
i'll never forget him being like why
does my iphone
listen to me and i was i was like all
right
like when you're going up to mark
zuckerberg and you're asking
how does facebook make money it's like
okay i mean
you just waste you know you have a
finite amount of time whenever you get
to ask questions here
it used to drive me absolutely nuts
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you